[Music]
don't let your throwing arm dead keep
the check there you're ready to punch
him in the face
don't let the arm pick it up don't let
go the neck don't let go the neck
these runners go someone start don't
wait for her go go go now don't wait for
her stay connected you're in your own
land now if you're waiting start again
for reps with no weight in between
stay connected here she comes Go Go yes
they connected like that keep going
don't wait go
change writer come on go around her head
don't pick her up go around her head
[Music]
just see your to get your get in the
middle of the Mott come on use your
center lock your Center news Sochi in
the middle so mushy
[Music]
don't leave the guard right in here
you're poking drop compress this spot
and then you'll lean on you you move out
of the way
you're just following him down so inside
the fingers he starts to lean on you
move out of the way to compress this
fine you followed it down I'm not taking
him down so don't pull on here you see
that whoa
full confront you or not father be done
and as he gets up I've rebounded away
same thing we get Stefan him out of the
way Mike around his head and he goes by
followed him down keep the check doors
armed who did keep the check he gets up
following him and he's already right
here down boom boom follow the head move
it in here so it's not kind no it's not
what you're thinking where you go 180 we
turn him and then throw them backwards
you get that it's it's a it's spirally
everything is sparely so Connor would
just watch him play no attention to me
and watch what his bodies BBC see what
his body
remember he throw falling people don't
throw people down
[Music]
you're on his shoulder you don't even
touch it his neck area nope knee down he
know you cut on his arm
don't cut on his arm you don't need to
cut it as arm you're gonna twirl him you
don't want to troll him all right your
hand you take it on it's keeping his arm
towards his inside not towards this
outside
push him in with that arm that's it
there you go good
long
don't let your who's dead at the bottom
you did keep you feet under you basic so
trying to swing him around less compress
him and let him fall compress him and
let him fall and you follow the fall
good try it again compress it let it
fall whoops
a little close right you gonna get
behind a basic start over good so it's a
little far you're a little far when you
do the measure use your hand in the
elbow there you go
put yourself words effortless there you
go little too far you want less space
you don't really want to give him space
as you move around go to where you his
head there you go a little shy though
you got on your biceps your shoulder
goes there not just like that shoulder
there you go okay a little far right
we're not gonna protect you forever okay
you got to get that inside leg and arm
down it's irregular back break Bella
don't let go the neck don't let go the
next change Turner
let's go go someone start keep you on
the arm you're still training you're
still learning
don't let the arm be a little straight
though right need a curve curve along
you have a tendency to go too far don't
go where you want to go go where they're
telling you to go compress you're
spinning her around compressors fine
drop make your hand heavy on her neck
then it'll happen
[Music]
that's it too far again you gotta find
that inside hand yes too far again is
not us now you're spinning him it's not
gonna work when you go standing you have
to compress to shoot down down
[Music]
so you don't have this balance on the
first swoop because you're not doing in